now performing for her delighted
audience
she will need years of reconstructed
surgery
the skin's growing over her eyes making
it hard for her to see
and her ears need entirely rebuilding
from her feet to her legs to her
amputated hands dalal will need medical
help for a long time
but she's made astonishing progress
since she was rushed to hospital at the
start of this year
she was covered in burns barely alive
and all on her own
her family's tent in idlib in syria went
up in flames the fire killed her elder
sister yasmine and left her with
terrible burns whilst her other four
siblings and parents somehow managed to
get out
she was transported to turkey as a
medical emergency and we followed her
fight to stay alive ever since her
battle stunned the turkish doctors and
prompted an outpouring of generosity
around the world
against all the odds in may she was well
enough to leave the hospital which had
been her and her father's home for more
than four months
it was an emotional moment for the
doctors who'd got so attached to her
and today is another milestone dalal's
having her first outpatient laser
treatment
every step of this journey is full of
pain for the toddler
[Music]
she's anesthetized so they can work
trying to soften her tight and tender
scars
all this treatment's possible only after
some funds were provided by a family
foundation who saw our report
after the laser dalal is sleepy and sore
and very hungry and thirsty
she's learned to cope with her injuries
and is managing remarkably well
but her father anxiously calls the rest
of the family still in syria to reassure
them she's okay
dalal's mother fatima and her siblings
are in idlib in a tent
this is the only way they've been able
to see each other since the fire they're
just one family amongst millions of
syrian refugees who fled their homes to
escape the war
but now they're finally leaving the camp
our british mothers raised thousands of
pounds to help pay for passports and
transport to reunite the family in
turkey
they leave behind thousands of other
children sheltering in camps on the
border
but before they depart syria without
knowing if they'll ever be able to
return they go to the graveyard filled
with the victims of war to say a last
goodbye to their daughter yasmin who
died in the fire
speak to her she beckons her other
daughters
i love you yasmin one says we're going
to see dad now hello
i wish you were with us says the other
waiting at the border on the turkish
side is dalal and her father abdel
fattah
and when the children see their father
and sister they can't hold back
they're delighted to be able to cuddle
dalal and immediately shower her with
affection
this is the first time they've been
together in six months
say hi to our friends their father tells
them
[Music]
fatima is heavily pregnant the journey
the stress the emotion of it all is
enormous
she can barely believe she's reached
safety and the family is one again
now begins the task of mother and
daughter getting to know each other
again
alex crawford sky news turkey